[Cameraman] Can you tell
when people have accents?
[Cece] Absolutely.
Oh, you got a strong one.
[both laughing]
♩♩
Hi, my name is Cece Bell,
and El Deafo is
the story of my childhood
and adjusting to
a sudden hearing loss.
[muted tone]
[tone]
This is my own
unique personal story.
There are so many ways
to be a deaf person.
Some people
might be like me
and wear hearing aids
and lip read.
Some might not wear
hearing aids at all
and prefer sign language.
(Is anyone here deaf or hard of hearing?)
(That’s you, Cece!
Raise your hand!)
It’s very important for me
that the kids
who watch the show
are experiencing it
the way I experienced it.
You can read the book
and get the sense of
what speech is like,
for example,
from the speech balloons
but you can watch the show
and actually hear it.
(Is it working?)
The audio design
was really tough.
I want to be able
to explain
to hearing people
what this is like.
[muted speech]
(Hello, Cece.)
(Hello, Cece?)
[muted speech]
(Yes!)
(You listened and watched my lips)
[muted speech]
(and figured out what I said.)
If my character on the show
can see the person’s
mouth move
then the audio
is pretty much clear.
There's a little bit
of distortion because
we're trying to
share with viewers
what it might sound
like to wear hearing aids.
[loud whistle]
[muted speech]
(Alright kids,)
(you know the drill.)
[muted speech]
(Let’s break into two teams)
(for some major kickball action!)
But then, there are
situations that happen
where that comprehension
just goes away.
Maybe the lights
get turned off
(Oh no.)
or a character faces away.
(206 bones in the...)
[inaudible speech]
And I think by recreating
that experience,
it's sort of a reminder
of how to be with a person
that doesn't hear very well.
You know, don't shout.
Remember that the person
needs to see your face.
You know, be empathetic.
Think about
what it would feel like.
And this is a very direct way
to help kids understand
what that feels like.